the IMF is uniquely trained and highly  motivated specialists without equal  immune to any countermeasures but it is  an agency of chaos the time has come to  dissolve the IMF now I want you to  choose your next words very carefully  where is hun last I heard he was  tracking the syndicate  how come the CIA has never discovered  any Intel regarding the syndicate you  want to polite answer or the truth  we've never met before right fireman  Benji Ethan where are you The Syndicate  is real a rogue nation trained into what  we do an aunty IMF they're coming after  us with everything they've got you ready  this may very well be our last mission  let's make it count what's the play you  want to bring down the syndicate  it's impossible  how do you know we can trust him best  four times  desperate measures  dig your seat belt on you asking me that  now  oh hey boys what did I miss  Ethan  open the door  open the door yeah I'm trying  oh my god  you